thanks for the right oh no problem what
brought you to LA where you from
originally I am from Ohio
get out I'm from Ohio we're from
Cleveland field sure you really get me
to do you know Brandon Borman yep
Janet Murdoch Oh Krystal Levine no
champagne yeah yeah I've dated jumpin oh
my gosh this is so weird
your 400v turn man that's so weird that
they know like exactly one yeah I don't
even know what 400 people looks like the
GPS knows where 400 feet looks like from
like outer space
it's fries about kitchen I don't really
pay attention when you're eating friends
it's like red okay that red lipstick on
in a red dress it's like turn and old
you want to go all the way I'm just
saying I'd be better with ketchup on it
I'm not saying we should be prepared for
it but I am saying if I feel comfortable
with that
my assassinating zombies it feels like
it would be like scary at first and then
everything boring if it gets boring then
that Rodgers means I'm real good at it
within the you know
you know what I have recently that I
loved what it was a dosa one of the
worst things I ever had was an ostrich
burger I also tried age but caramel
dipped hotdogs have you had jerky dipped
in chocolate my boyfriend tried ox balls
before